Welcome.
Welcome,
welcome.
We're so excited to have you here at Google.
Thank you so much for taking time to come.
And this is Jessica,
well
two dope Queens,
so we're so happy to be here.
Thanks for having us.
Absolutely.
So just,
um,
for those of you who don't have as extensive of a background,
about two dope Queens,
two dope queens started as a comedy show between two best friends in Brooklyn,
hosted by these two wonderful ladies here to my left.
Um,
it launched and as a podcast in March,
2016 and it is produced by Wny c studios.
Um,
so,
uh,
but the,
the two dope Queens podcasts is appraised by the Guardian by the New York Times.
It was actually rated the best podcast of 2016.
So let's give it up.
What
they talked about it
in New York.
Yes,
it is amazing.
Right?
So he's going to let that soak in in Cimarron sparkle for a second.
So you have stays in three starting soon,
is that right?
Yes.
Three starts Tuesday,
April 4th.
And you're ready?
Yeah.
Ready to.
All right.
We have some pretty cool guests that are coming.
We've heard that we have Jon Hamm.
Gabrielle Union.
Gotcha.
I was going to be two dope queens and another queen.
Yeah,
absolutely.
All right,
so let's get into some questions.
Cool.
I tried to set up some hard hitting questions.
Let's not get too serious.
Okay.
We're going to
go in really deep at first.
Great.
Whatever you want.
Right.
I want to talk to you guys about your show and the context of modern comedy and
intersectional feminism.
How do you feel your,
show us where it fits in?
It's that social commentary.
That's a great question.
It just seems like such a,
normally it's like not hard hitting.
To me it feels like just like a straight,
can you think about it all the time?
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
when we started the podcast we just recognize that the podcasting world was very
height and um,
and everyone kind of sounds like I reclast which is great cause he has a
beautiful voice.
But you know,
I think it can make,
you know,
women or people of color or people from the Lgbtq plus community feel like,
well this isn't a space for us because the only things that are getting shine
or,
or breaking on mainstream wise are white people.
And so when we started show,
we just said that we wanted to do shows,
comedy shows,
especially in New York.
What's your also mostly white?
Uh,
so we just went to do shows with women,
people of Color,
people in the queer community.
We're like,
there's so many brilliant people that aren't,
you know,
necessarily on like Netflix is radar,
like comedy central's radar yet,
but they're really talented and funny and they have stories to tell that are
just as valid and just as important as like the white dude stories,
you know what I mean?
And sometimes even like more important like,
well,
and like,
sorry [inaudible] you can't sing either.
Good luck with that,
but sorry.
I know it's too much.
[inaudible] it's like,
it cracks me up because it's so triggering for you.
[inaudible]
and,
but anyway,
the point is that we wanted to just kind of do something that was going to be
representative of our conversations with the people that we hang out with and
like the conversation that you guys have at home or at work or at the gym.
So
yeah.
[inaudible] the city lifestyle sort of reference.
None of us [inaudible] sure.
You guys like talk to you guys like talk or he was just mortified.
Karen counts payable wants to talk.
Yeah.
Well I know like
sang about we both,
we're both members of Equinox Aka and so we're always joking about going to like
a class or something together and I'm always like,
I don't know,
I'm not really available just because the idea of like being super close here
and sweating,
I'm really scared.
I'm scared.
It's like vulnerable.
It's like the real me.
I might be ashy.
My Lips get dry.
Kalatu used to get my core strong.
It's fine.
Let's do it together.
Okay.
I think I might.
Okay,
I'll see you upstairs like after
now that we've covered Lala land and how much we hated it,
it was fine.
To be honest.
I did it
team Pv here with the hated la La land.
So now that we've covered that,
making sure that the land escape
wasn't super white and male.
Um,
let's talk about the impact that you think this show has had.
What do you think the impact the show has had in 2016 and what would you like it
to be in the next year?
You know,
it's funny,
I,
I feel like the best part about,
for me at least with two dope queens is that now when we go out around Brooklyn,
there's always really cool women that come up and they're like,
oh dude,
I love your podcast.
And it feels like I'm hanging out with my friends.
And that to me is like really important.
And that's kind of why
a part of the reason why we do the show is because we like each other and we
think friendship is important and female friendship is like really at the core
of this podcast.
And I really,
I do think and hope that we encourage like female friendship in general.
And I also just feel like people are always tweeting at us trying to figure out
like who the comedian was that we had on our show and it will be like a lesbian
comedian or like an like anybody of the LGBT community and I feel like they're
also getting a platform.
So I think that's been such a huge part of everything.
Um,
and I also think like we reach people that we never expected would be into the
show.
Like Kevin Bacon was like,
I love it.
They showed me,
he's like,
I subscribe to it and I listened to it every week and I was like,
haven't you have so many things going on?
You know what I mean?
Is this was like crazy because again,
I love this show.
Like my daughter like listens to it and it was just like,
that's really cool.
And like Bano send us flowers.
I mean in 10 minutes,
I made 10 minutes and I'll bring it up,
but she be [inaudible] we were looking at a u two fan in the car on the way
here.
Oh,
Youtube blog news.
But it's got like 94 followers and a lot of the photos were blurry out of focus
now formatted oddly working on it.
Well my youtube news,
but it was like really cool because of Jasmine.
I do like a lot of philanthropic stuff for Islam.
Two Dope Queens and uh,
and we did some for a poverty is sexist campaign and have bond would be like,
thank you for doing that.
It was really cool.
It was pretty good.
Yeah.
So I think the fact that we can highlight people and also people that were fans
of can be into our stuff on what we're doing feels kind of crazy because
sometimes I'm like,
I'm just talking about nonsense.
Yeah.
You know,
were just talking about things
we like and things that tickle us and make us laugh.
And I know for me,
my,
one of my favorite parts about the show is making you laugh and I feel like he's
told me you feel the same way too.
And so it's really exciting that people respond to that.
It's like,
oh cool,
we can do more of what's fun for us.
And people really like it.
That rules.
That's the dream.
Yeah.
It was cool
listening to hated it the other day.
There was at least two to three seconds where the two of you are laughing and I
found myself laughing and it was just really interesting to be sitting in the
middle of Google and I'm just laughing really loud,
laughing with a group of girlfriends.
But that's good.
Yeah.
Disturbing.
Some of my coworkers who are here.
That's all right.
Sorry.
Not really.
Okay.
So in that vein,
what do you think is cause
the most single bit of positive feedback you've received about the show?
Um,
uh,
we don't get it.
No one ever remember.
They don't,
um,
I don't know.
It's just like when it's just like a,
uh,
like when we did,
um,
sketch fest at Cobbs and this I guess was two years ago and his black woman came
up to us and she was like starting to cry a little bit and I was like,
Whoa,
this is like Bieber level?
Yeah.
[inaudible] and his name.
Okay.
Maybe not Justin Bieber,
maybe like the least famous Joan.
His brother.
Yeah.
It was like comfortable with being Kelly.
She likes just started to cry and she said,
you know,
you guys like your podcast me so much to me.
Like these are conversations I have with my girlfriends and I just felt like I
wasn't represented in the media and the show is like a way for me to feel like
I'm looking at myself in the mirror.
So it was like,
that was pretty cool.
That's really cool.
I remember like I don't,
we had Gabrielle Union on the show.
She gave us really cool feedback.
And like she,
she's a fan of the show and she was saying how she loves listening to it because
she feels like back in the day she couldn't get away with as a black actress
saying the things that we are allowed to say.
And so it's really,
really cool that we are able to express ourselves freely.
And we were like,
well thank you for what you did.
And so having like a legend say something like that to us.
I know we just died and then we like came back to life.
No,
we definitely,
so now you're here.
Okay.
And so,
all right.
So that's super positive.
We can see how it impacts you.
I think that the energy you get,
you guys obviously give back to your show,
right?
Yeah.
But what do you think has been the most critical feedback that you've received
and how do you manage that?
That's funny.
You know,
I,
I stopped reading like any sort of reviews of us a long time ago,
like right after we started the show.
But one of them that I read was,
um,
then my laugh was annoying,
which is fine.
All cause it's like there's nothing I can do.
Um,
but also that it,
they're like,
it's not for me.
Like I don't like the front,
like the inside friendship stuff and it's like,
oh well that's like,
that's crazy.
Literally one of the most successful shows of all time.
It's called [inaudible] small talk with strangers.
Just call it [inaudible] long have you hated things that are good.
It's like we're not for you.
Yeah.
The up and decided they hated friendships that,
you know what I mean?
That's just stupid.
I used to be on top of the,
um,
as we have a fan page on another website,
and I want to say it here,
cause I don't know if you guys are beefing or not.
Just kidding.
It's Facebook.
So is that of me?
So it's
okay.
Okay,
cool.
Uh,
and so I used to check the messages and there was this one guy,
it's always like a dude,
of course,
some freaking Tom or town.
Yeah.
And he didn't like how much we said the word like,
and so he was telling us that we should work on it.
And I,
you know,
I'm thinking literally,
this is just how everyone talks.
Everyone says,
like Barack Obama says like,
you know what I mean?
Justin Trudeau says like,
I've heard it,
you know,
like that's just a filler word,
get over it.
And it just,
stuff like that where men,
what I'm trying and tell us how we should speak differently,
that would be more pleasing to them.
And it's just there
before you finish.
It isn't for you.
And it's all
trains people to think that the way that women naturally speak is somehow
incorrect in the way that men speak is somehow the ideal and what people strive
for.
And I'm just,
no,
no.
Yeah,
just speak how you want to speak.
And so that was kind of really irritating.
And then I think sometimes people will say,
you know,
you and Jace,
Jace,
can we call you [inaudible] to say race?
And then I say,
[inaudible],
you're one of my best friends and you just call me j.
So remember that forever.
This word to say that Jess and I talked too much about race and it was just kind
of like one we don't and also these are arcs
not too much because we don't talk about race in a real way in the first place,
which is why you know,
we have the present,
we have,
you know,
sorry,
let that simmer,
which is why we have the president we have,
but I think
talking about,
you know,
racist cab drivers are bad customer service.
These are all things that people of color go through in the country.
These are all things that every day we face these micro aggressions at your pace
stomach.
Like
oftentimes you,
I know for us,
we grew up in the suburbs.
It's like you're around white people who oftentimes don't understand what
microaggressions are and you have to hold your tongue.
It's like you have to really keep a compose and then when you find somebody who
is a person of color or a member of the Lgbtq community who understands that
it's the best connection.
It's like the most life affirming thing ever.
It's like,
um,
you know when women get catcalled at all,
like most of the time that's a very personal experience that you,
you just log and then you go about your day.
But if you explain that to another woman,
it feels so good and it feels really life affirming.
And that to me also,
this is a show about like friendships with people of color and that's how we
talk
to each other.
So it really is,
that means that you don't have enough friends that are minorities.
I think if you feel like we talk about race too much because every day we are
reminded of our race and we are constantly confronted with that in our day to
day.
And I just feel like it's the most natural thing to talk about things that make
you laugh or sad or angry or happy with like how you look and how your race and
I think Phoebe,
you,
you alluded to it,
but I just want to make sure that,
um,
that we talk about it a little bit more.
You did have an episode where you guys talked about an experience in a cab where
the racist cab driver,
and in terms of the validation of not just talking as friends,
but it's also really valuable that you talked about your thought process as you
went through that experience,
like was that racist?
Was that not racist and do I react now?
Do I not react now?
Do I allow,
you know,
my partner who's a white male to react,
how do I process this,
this feeling?
Do you find that a lot of your viewers respond to that as well?
Not just how you react together,
but sort of the verbal storytelling that goes with how you experience racism as
black women?
Yeah.
I mean,
I think when,
I think we both have racist cab drivers in the same way.
Yeah.
Sinked up like it was our period.
So it was just very funny how we both were like,
hey,
so this happened.
She's like,
well,
this happened to me.
I,
those are conversations that happen all the time,
every day.
And I think part of it is that people think that racism happens one time to you,
one time in your life and that's it.
And it's like,
no,
it happens every week or every month,
every year.
And so I think when we both have these different experiences at like how justice
cab driver only stopped once he saw her boyfriend or how the guy said the n word
because he was like,
well my daughter is half black so I can say it.
And it was just these weird,
weird,
weird kind of like be pro supposed to live in a post racial society but things
like this are still happening.
Yeah.
So I think it just kind of made the black,
the black woman hopefully who listened to the episode be like,
yeah,
how my own really shitty cab experience and I maybe I didn't tell anybody and
like the fact that we said something,
maybe they were like,
well next time I am going to say something and I'm going to let people know that
this is terrible.
Like when I was in that situation,
I didn't say anything to the guy because I was like,
this is weird.
This is crazy.
He knows where I live.
Like I don't want to anger any song,
anyone who's driving me.
But you know,
it is no situations where you got to,
you hopefully learned that you can stand up for yourself more.
Right?
Yeah.
And that's,
I think the show has given me a lot of things.
But one of the things that it's given me strength to sort of speak up a lot,
I feel there's this idea
of the black woman as angry or confrontational,
but oftentimes I find that I shrink into myself and I get really quiet when
something is like if there's a microaggression or if there is something racist
that's happened.
But I feel like the more that I do our show and the more that we get feedback
from other black one because really we're just two black women in a,
in a world full of black women,
you know?
Um,
I'm like,
oh,
I should speak up more.
It kind of gives me the courage to speak out.
I think,
right.
And you did it so differently,
right?
Like so in that episode you at one point when you got into the cab and he had
hailed the cab,
you said
[inaudible] it's my white boyfriend.
Yeah.
And then you responded
and said,
hi,
I'm black.
Great subject line really gets people high alert.
Oh Shit.
[inaudible] I got a refund.
And they're like,
we're going to reprimand this guy.
And I was like,
great.
Awesome.
Yeah.
So,
um,
thank you for that.
Thank you for going down that talk.
So that was definitely for me.
That was one of my favorite episodes.
If you haven't seen it,
you need to go start listening to the entire podcast,
but start with that one.
Um,
yeah,
it was awesome.
Um,
what advice would you give other black women but just intersection of women?
Because I think we've talked a lot about intersectionality and about allyship,
but trying to get into this industry,
trying to start a podcast,
trying to really make their voices known.
Um,
do you want to go first?
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
first of all,
please start a podcast because the amount of feedback that we've gotten from
Trudeau Queens is great,
but you know,
there are so many black female voices that need to be heard.
And I think the response that we've gotten is just evidence that like,
oh,
there needs to be more black female stories out there.
Um,
but also,
um,
if you're doing it with another person,
find someone that like excites you and that you can geek out with and that you
enjoy.
And also if you're doing it with another person,
realize that it's kind of a marriage and it's a relationship and it's a team and
you have to sort of figure out how to work together and do a give and take and
communicate and figure that out.
Um,
and also be the most yourself that you possibly can is the biggest one because
it's super valuable and it keeps it from being just another like podcast about
white dudes white knit up.
Um,
just be yourself because that is the most interesting,
fascinating thing.
And if you're speaking from a point of truth,
then it will resonate with people.
Really.
It's like impossible
for it to not resonate that that would be my advice once you're like,
yeah.
Um,
I think just if you think you have a story to tell this worth hearing,
you're probably right.
So you should just go for it.
And it doesn't matter if there's not an example,
they're a blueprint for you to follow.
You can be the first one and you can kind of figure things out yourself and what
works and what doesn't.
So it's like don't be afraid to take a leap.
And like Wyc is like getting really more involved with other things.
And so we're both wearing pins for their latest podcast is coming out called
Nancy on April 9th and it's an Lgbtq plus podcast to be a lot like storytelling
and also like investigative stuff.
And they just decided,
hey,
we want our voices out there and these are stories that should be told.
And now it's a podcast,
a WYC.
So I think if he just really believes in your idea a thousand percent and maybe
you can't start a Wyc,
maybe have to start in your,
your apartment and do a podcast.
I did that.
I was doing a podcast in my apartment in Brooklyn and it's Shitty one bedroom
apartment and
there she saw it,
allegedly did a podcast.
I have to set it up.
I accidentally deleted it.
[inaudible] that would never happen.
Maybe get a producer because I did not know how to work soundcloud properly.
It,
it was three hours of my time and I'll never get back.
[inaudible] and spades sat at her kitchen table.
It's Google told us
I ain't [inaudible] but yeah,
to start out wherever you can and hone your voice and hone your vision because
the thing that's gonna set you apart the most,
like you think it's,
Oh,
I have to sound like this,
I have to do what's already been done at going to set you apart the most is if
you stay true to your voice.
Because ultimately people want that new thing.
And a lot of times people are scared to take the risk.
On a new thing,
but if you could just establish your own stuff in your own following and just
believing your own vision and be a business person about it.
That's the other thing is not just creativity.
You have to be a business person about whatever endeavor you go into,
you're going to be fine and it's not going to happen overnight.
It's going to take awhile.
But you know,
keep the faith,
be yourself.
Yeah,
because he afraid to start.
Yeah.
Be All the way,
all the way,
all the way yourself.
You don't try to moderate or change your voice and it's the hardest thing to do.
I think it's like life's journey Hashtag self help.
It's a marriage helpers like,
yeah.
So you two are best friends in real life.
Really,
really best friends.
What's it like?
I'm going to ask you a few questions.
Hey,
we talked a lot about what are the sort of feelings,
motivations that you have to have really being true to yourself.
How did you guys get started?
Like how did you decide you were hanging out having pizza?
Like,
how did you look over to your girl and say,
we should start a comedy show?
Well,
we met,
um,
when I did background and daily show a piece you did about black hair in the
military and I had already,
no,
she was,
because she was in upright citizens brigade as was I.
And she like had a white bay.
She was like really
funny.
And so we met,
uh,
that was July,
2014 and uh,
I was just like,
Hey,
do you want to come and do my podcasts?
Um,
and I was like,
not Jane.
Like I interviewed,
it was like,
it's super [inaudible] interview.
Why it's an act like this is like legit.
That was like,
we do a new,
like different recording process,
dial up on me that's like black on black crime,
but you have to learn I'm experiment or I'm like Benjamin frame.
You're literally not like
that is so do some stuff
you like to in a podcast.
Benjamin Franklin.
Yes.
You know,
and training anyways.
And so we just kinda hit it off and when we're taking the podcast and she said
her birthday was coming up and asked her what she wanted to do,
she said,
well,
I always wanted to do stand up.
And I said,
well,
I do a monthly standup show at UCB.
Do you want to cohosted with me as a goof?
It'll be fun.
We'll just like hang out.
And then like,
there'll be like a nice treat for the audience.
And then we ended up having so much fun doing it.
They were like,
all right,
let's do another show together.
And they were like,
let's just keep doing this.
And then we moved to union hall because we were like,
we want to get paid.
ECB doesn't pay,
which is fine.
I mean,
that's like this.
Do you write whatever you wanted?
We need a sidebar.
I'm a business
person.
Must Jaycee thing about,
um,
I reaching real high with these legends.
[inaudible]
ruining his life.
And we were both,
we had a really amazing show,
a union hall.
We were both like,
this could be a podcast.
Yeah.
And I was like,
well,
what if we just record ourselves?
And she was like,
we should make it perfect.
You delete it on the track record is you have to read it.
I noticed that people at a Wyc LED's,
you know,
figure out like a game plan,
like pitch in and everything and the rest is just history.
That's great.
So,
okay,
what is,
what has been your favorite episode and your favorite guests and what,
um,
are you going to say,
are you going to sing Johnny?
I'm trying to think.
Carrie Brownstein on and I was cool and obsessed with her and so that was kind
of a dream come true.
I had seen her in high school a couple times,
like doing shows and stuff and I look,
we're such fans of Portlandia and um,
she was amazing and Super Fun and I think we crowd surfed with her too.
Oh,
[inaudible]
yeah,
I hope so.
I hope we did.
Thanks Joanna.
Phoebe personally,
crowd surf with John,
him and I got video of that and that was really fun because
yeah,
literally after our wedding we just crowd served out.
Yeah.
[inaudible] that was our Jewish,
but thank you.
Yeah,
that was amazing.
No,
and then I realized too,
that episode was very overwhelming because,
or I haven't been single for a while,
but I realized when we were doing the Jon Hamm episode that I was like very
overwhelmed and so I couldn't say things that were real or I couldn't say words.
I couldn't put things together coherently.
And uh,
I realized that about myself as like reverting back into the third grade.
Me.
Um,
yeah,
those are very,
I think it was great.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Cause I really like feel like I spent a lot during that time
fixing everywhere.
Part of it is because he is hands down the most attractive person we ever had on
the show.
Right.
No tea,
no shade.
It,
everybody who's done the show know what y'all know what happened.
Um,
just the Hamercaz [inaudible] that's insane.
That up later
we,
we were trying,
before we did the La show,
we told Shannon,
um,
was,
uh,
one of our producers,
our podcasts are like our dream guests or ru Paul and John Hamm and we're still
holding out for rude,
so rude.
Please,
please my ways.
And so,
um,
John Social Nola reached out to John because he was supposed to do something
else and then he couldn't and he told Shinoa but I really want to do two dope
queens.
And we were both like,
wait,
he listens to two dope queens.
It was crazy.
It was like,
this is madmen.
Um,
but like [inaudible] jobs,
um,
and yeah,
we voted,
voted,
voted.
Yeah,
let's not cause it's that now I'm getting,
yeah,
okay,
we're going to be a [inaudible].
Well he just showed up and he was so nice.
He was like,
I love the show.
And he went on,
we were like,
[inaudible] we didn't do any of that.
We're like,
what do you want to do?
And he's like,
I'll follow your lead.
It's totally fine.
I was like,
this is like really sexual all time.
Just explain the
to me.
Right.
And so basically we were just like,
we're just going to hit on you for 20 minutes.
And he was like,
cool.
Yeah,
being a good sport.
But he was like,
whoa.
He says,
I agree Dan a little,
a little bit.
We do sometimes if we have like a celebrity guest that nobody knows is coming
out will be like,
can we get some water?
We're thirsty.
It'll just be awesome.
Thirsty.
Can we get some water?
Then I do.
The celebrity comes out
just water.
But it was crazy because with him,
he's such an amazing actor that he liked,
took an extra second and we genuinely didn't know it was coming out or not only
like literally acted with Johnny.
I do like a stage [inaudible] we've covered all the academy award.
Okay.
So he like came out.
It was amazing.
We like acted with him.
Yeah,
it was cool
gas holding out for Rupaul.
Look in the camera.
It RuPaul,
Rupaul Charles
this Friday.
Please just do or she wants to be.
We will love you.
Come.
Okay,
so last question and we're going to try it.
We're going to try to be serious,
but I know that we can.
Um,
okay,
so
how do you balance your need to bring joy,
levity?
It's bring your voice,
highlight the voices of the other great comedians and other great actors with
some of the very real traumatizing,
I can't even find another word for it.
Political Change and environment that we find ourselves in.
Um,
I was literally studying your post election episode,
uh,
trying to get through the fields,
trying to work through the field.
Yeah.
How did you plan that show?
How do you process this now?
How do you sort of bifurcate what's happening with the social political
landscape and the goals of two dope queens?
Well,
I think that episode was Joanna.
I think that was your idea,
right?
To do like,
yeah,
it was the post election,
Huh?
Yeah.
Were you not paying any attention?
Cool.
[inaudible] our Google Talk Rachel.
But yeah,
we dragged you don't deserve,
but like pay attention to Google,
but also she like does she like,
and it's every one of us.
He loved me,
Joanna,
like,
um,
so yeah,
who are all just feeling like a little,
cause I think we all kind of assumed that like a mirror.
It could be like,
okay,
the joke is over.
We're going to like not elect Donald Trump.
Yes.
Even when we had to record that,
we had to record two versions of that episode and the first one was if Hillary
won and then we were like,
great.
And then like,
well why don't we just just in case do the other one where she didn't when we
were like,
what the fuck you talking [inaudible]
and then yeah,
it happened.
And uh,
I don't even want to say Voldemort if you read a Harry Potter Book
Bend.
And we were just kind of feeling like,
I think everyone was,
a lot of people were in a state of shock.
And so I think we all just agree with Rachel that it would be good to have an
episode where we just addressed it openly and honestly and be like,
Hey,
let's just talk through what we're feeling right now.
Just get these emotions out.
Because I know like I was crying.
Yeah.
Day One was
just the idea that somebody who is supposed to represent you completely doesn't
have your interests at heart is no.
Has Your,
has your really your destruction really.
And it's really,
really deeply upsetting.
Yeah.
Like honestly,
like I go to therapy every week and my therapist has been like,
yeah,
all everybody wants to talk about is the fact that we have this president.
How it bothers them.
Just yes,
but continue.
Yeah.
No,
that was good.
And so I think when we just sat down,
it wasn't like Jess and I had anything prepare.
We really just spoke from the heart of how we felt.
We said some ignorant things.
I think they cut out of
fuck,
I want to hear the [inaudible],
you know,
like we can like just go off and this is less light can really pop off.
Yeah.
So is this,
where are these are for our techs,
right.
No,
I felt really kind of,
um,
know.
I think it felt like Cathartic for us.
And I think for a lot of listeners we kind of stay a lot of things.
They were thinking.
So it just felt really good.
And I think going forward with the show,
we just want to keep doing the same thing with our show,
which is just like highlight different voices.
Um,
promote comedy.
That's about punching up,
not punching down and you know,
just keep telling our stories.
And I think if everyone just keeps like putting their stories out there and
putting their lives out there and say,
we're going to drown out the nonsense,
we're going to jot out the haters are going to drown out the ugliness.
Yeah.
So it's nice too,
because I feel like one of the reasons comedy is great because it sort of
transcends differences in a way.
And I feel like if people can listen to our podcast and feel a little bit of
comfort for 45 minutes to an hour,
then we've done our job.
You know,
just taking a second and just really being like,
oh,
it's going to be okay.
Oh,
there's still great comedy out there.
okay.
This is like a transgender person doing standup.
Oh cool.
You know,
it's,
if,
if we can continue to up with those voices then we're going to be okay the next
four years.
Yeah.
Well on that.
No thank you for the encouragement because I think we all need it.
I think everyone watching needs it.
I know that can feel the energy in the room.
For those of you watching the energy in the room is amazing.
I just want to make sure that we actually open up the floor to the room.
Yeah.
I want to thank you ladies for coming.
[inaudible]
and are you ready for round fire questions
right?
[inaudible]
and make sure that you balance load the mikes guys.
So don't cry one.
Anyway,
go ahead.
Hello.
What's your name?
[inaudible]
they came out less to him than I wanted it to,
I believe.
Anyway,
my question is,
uh,
whenever I've listened to your podcast,
like my favorite parts.
So like actually my favorite part is before the show actually starts and you're
talking to you like the sound guy.
I thought I like,
I start crying during that part cause it's so hilarious and I am a questions
actually.
Have you thought of like making episodes of just the banter and just the
friendship,
like,
like a few episodes without guests?
No,
actually that feedback.
Um,
and we just,
we really want to make sure that we are giving platforms to people that
otherwise wouldn't have it.
So I think we want to use it for that.
Yeah.
And we do like the bonus shows like we did the advice episode,
which is really fun and my brother like wants to do an advice episode.
Yeah.
So I think stuff like that,
those episodes,
yeah.
Get like a lot of us.
But like she said like we really want to showcase people and I think that's the
heart of the show showcasing.
Well No,
we're the heart of the show.
Right.
But they're like,
they're the,
the guests are like the risks of this show.
I don't know
that they have risks.
Okay.
Yeah.
The forearm of the show.
Whenever there is the other body parts that aren't the heart and we just want to
make sure those beers.
Hi.
Thank you for coming to talk to us and thank you for your work.
Thanks.
What's your name?
Can everyone just say their name?
I'm so many questions and I love so many white guys,
but I'll keep it to one cause you've touched about this a little bit,
how much you leverage your network for your guests cause your guests are
awesome.
And then how much do you put your wishlist together?
So like as professionals and for all being business people about what we do,
how much would you recommend that we leverage what we have or like go out and
kind of just put it in the universe for your dream?
Um,
I mean I'm all about putting these in universe and talking about things all the
time.
It does manifest it.
Um,
but you work at Google.
Like I would literally just be like,
I,
hi,
I work at Google.
Can I get this for free?
[inaudible] would be like,
sure.
[inaudible] so you have
such a great,
and they're like,
you know,
I think with our show,
because we found out like,
you know,
Carrie Brown,
like all these swells were like listening to the show.
We were like,
oh,
we should just ask them to do it.
They won't say no,
and so I think once we kind of know that it's on someone's radar,
then go for it.
Then we asked them like on a first date.
Um,
but yeah,
you work at Google,
like lead with that and be like,
who'd done this?
This,
this.
Yeah.
There's a whole floor of our office that's just dedicated to seasons.
He's in season.
Like we have snacks.
Walls of Moss.
Yeah.
And like a massage chair and five restaurants on the one floor.
It's like Oprah design this place and then left.
Yeah.
My work is done.
She likes
gold.
Her fairy dust.
They've seen one floor.
Yeah.
Can you kind of drag you guys because that is fucking amazing.
I work out of my,
like off of a couch in my apartment.
Yeah.
So just
lunch exclusively.
Hey,
you're no word.
You use that power because a lot of times people will be like,
oh,
Google,
okay.
All like listen to this.
As opposed to like,
hi,
I'm Mike.
I work,
I've worked for myself.
And they're like,
oh boom.
So yeah,
I use
the Google connection for sure.
Yeah.
Bar over to the right.
Thank you so much for being here,
Mike.
Hi Mike.
How tall?
I am
six feet tall.
If it's like
six feet over and like,
yeah,
it's more of my body.
It's like,
I'm like,
oh.
It's like,
what do you do at Google?
MERCI programs.
So on the recruitment side of things,
that's how are you like leg?
Are you single?
Like what's up?
He seems
to
have a
headboard.
Yeah.
It's like a sign that you're like,
oh man,
that's cool.
Yeah.
That's cool.
So do you live
live in Crown Heights?
Williamsburg?
No,
on I really,
really crown heights.
Okay,
that's cool.
Yeah.
I
ask him where he gets his clothes.
I like clothes or cools at urban outfitters.
Was this second hand cool.
Even better.
Yeah.
We're going to make this happen.
We should be,
you should ask the question.
Yes.
This is how many days from now on.
I'm just going to like hold like Q and a
question.
Yeah,
sorry,
sorry.
Not Sorry.
So thinking about allyship as being a really awesome thing in general,
one of the things that I've been talking about and reading about recently is the
idea of people who were like book misogynists.
I had a friend who said,
I just saw get out,
I feel like a woke racist.
Like I just didn't really know what I'm thinking about these things.
First,
have you had any situations and anecdotally that you're like,
no,
I thought you were on my team and then this happened.
And then also
generally other than like shutting down the black every day
country,
literally
insistently shutting down the bullshit.
How do we prevent people from being so comfortable having that sort of identity?
You know what,
that's a good question.
Um,
I think it's a give and take.
I feel like first of all,
surround yourself with friends and people that are woke and you know,
our kind and nice in general.
We like aware of what's happening but also realize certain things are out of
your control too.
Like don't,
I think you should only do that to the extent that you're not exhausting
yourself and you're not tired.
Uh,
because one of my favorite things that my therapist says to me is,
you don't have to fight today.
It'll,
you could lift it.
Sometimes it's like good to crawl into bed and just watch reruns of Buffy the
vampire slayer or play the sims if you're me.
And I feel like it is
only doing it to an extent,
but also realizing that you can't control everybody and just making sure that
with your immediate group and when you're out and about,
you express your allyship and you make sure that you advocate as a,
as a white male,
make sure that you advocate for people that otherwise wouldn't get in rooms that
you're able to,
but only so much.
And uh,
I also think that if it's like your family,
like if it's like somebody's old,
if it's like grandma,
it's like she's going to die sooner
anyway.
Like let her go,
let her take it away.
Yeah.
Like it's like crazy.
She's seen a lot of crazy shit,
but it's like,
just let her go.
Um,
but yeah,
when is what is here.
Um,
I also,
I also think it's like we all have to remind ourselves that we always have to be
learning.
Abl just made it up.
Oh
yeah,
I stole it,
but I made it up.
Um,
you know,
like for me,
like I'm constantly like having to learn about trans issues cause that's
something that I don't know everything about and it's fine and be like,
I don't know everything.
Well let me go and read a book,
let me go educate myself.
And so I think it's great that your friend saw get out and then was like,
oh,
I'm more racist than I thought and that person's going to go check themselves
and like really like evaluate their behaviors so they can do better in the
future.
And I feel like once you know better,
you can then do better.
So I think just really just checking yourself and just being like,
Hey,
am I doing everything that I can?
It'd be like a good person.
Do I still think these shitty things were?
Do I occasionally make a bad joke that I shouldn't say?
But it makes people laugh.
And so that's why I do it.
So I think as long as people are really open about,
I don't have all the answers,
but I really want to learn and they're not like,
oh,
well Josh,
you're black.
So I'm going to ask you everything so I could learn about black people,
call me.
[inaudible] like turning someone into like,
you know,
learning in x,
but just like educating yourself I think is great.
Of course worse.
So you're the last question.
Oh my God,
no one else wants to ask a good question.
We like totally just like,
I understand.
It's a good,
it's a good strategy.
Hi,
my name's Kayla.
Just thank you for coming and thank you for everything that you do.
[inaudible]
so of what you can share,
what other side projects do you guys have up this year?
Uh,
for me,
uh,
I'm,
I'm going to be an La April and may cause I'm writing on the last season of
Portlandia I,
which is very exciting.
Um,
and yeah,
I think that's it.
Yeah.
And I just,
I went to Sundance with a movie called the incredible Jessica Dreams and we sold
it to Netflix.
So it'll be,
it'll be on Netflix on the next couple of months because we're very excited
for me there.
Thank you.
Should we just do this one last part or no?
Meghan didn't say no.
Go ahead.
Go,
go,
go.
I don't even have a question I just gave you,
if we have commentary
how you interact with people and so just tell Jessica that.
I mean she was so much more than John Stewart.
Oh,
thank you so much.
Like Ah,
that's true.
I appreciate it.
That's true.
Yeah.
Well capable of growing up.
I don't work in late night anymore.
Yeah.
Well we have a gift for you so we're going to get you a gift and we want to
thank you again for coming.
Why did you get us a massage chair?
We try [inaudible]
this is like Oprah's favorite things,
but
we don't get anything under your chairs.
You don't?
Oh,
this is for you.
Oh sure.
I love shirts.
I'm going to sleep and then get cold.
You need to put on this extra large.
Thank you so much.
Oh my God,
this is great.
You guys can go back to work.
Hi.